good morning Hank it's Tuesday today I
want to talk about the rigging of u.s.
presidential elections so travel back
with me to the election of 2004 where
incumbent Republican George W Bush
defeated Democrat John Kerry across the
country Bush received about 3 million
more votes that years and carried it but
of course the popular vote doesn't
matter in u.s. presidential elections
because of the electoral college this is
a strange and anachronistic feature of
our presidential elections explained in
detail by CGP grey here but quick
overview every state is allotted a
certain number of electoral votes based
on congressional representation so every
state has two senators so they get two
electoral votes and from there it's
decided by population like California
has 55 electoral votes whereas Montana
has 3 right so most states there are of
course exceptions because nothing is
ever easy in US politics a lot their
electoral votes to the candidate who
gets the most votes in that state a
candidate needs 270 total electoral
college votes to win and because you
might win some states by a wide margin
and lose others very narrowly it is
possible to win the popular vote in the
country but lose the election in fact
that's how George W Bush was elected in
2000 also if three or more candidates
get some electoral votes and that
prevents any one candidate from getting
a majority of electoral votes the
president is actually chosen by the US
House of Representatives this is
happened a couple times in US history
including in 1826 when Congress chose
John Quincy Adams to become president
even though Andrew Jackson had received
more votes anyway if you're thinking all
of this sounds bananas I agree but one
of the very few even arguable upsides to
the electoral college is that it makes
US presidential elections extremely hard
to rigged because we're not actually
having one election we're having
fifty-one elections each governed by the
separate states but in fact it's even
more complicated than that because in
every state counties and townships have
their own elections with their own
independent oversight so we're having
thousands of elections and this
massively decentralized system protects
against widespread fraud so back to 2004
there's not much question that george w
bush won the most votes in that election
the question is Ohio Kerry lost Ohio by
about a hundred eighteen thousand votes
if he'd won he would have been elected
president and lots of people on the Left
including by many accounts John Kerry
himself believed the voter suppression
and possible ballot fraud
essentially rigged that election like
there was a Rolling Stone cover story
about it you can still find blogs making
the case the claim goes like this Ohio
Secretary of State who oversees
elections was a Republican who
engineered long lines at polling places
also he purged voters from the rolls and
failed to get the names of 25% of newly
registered voters to polling places and
also somehow 150,000 votes in rural Ohio
were switched from Kerry to bush
possibly by a hacking electronic voting
machines possibly by a physically
altering ballots here's what actually
happened 25 percent of newly registered
voters did have to fill out provisional
ballots which is ridiculous and speaks
to how poorly the Ohio election was run
that year however almost exactly half of
those people cast their ballots for
George W Bush the voter rolls were
purged because they are required by law
to be purged because people died and/or
move actually I guess I don't really
need the end or they're mostly they just
die or move right also none of the
150,000 purportedly switched votes was
actually switched there were however
long lines at polling places which did
disenfranchise voters but not in a way
that would have affected the outcome of
Ohio's presidential election the 2004
ohio election was poorly run and it did
not reflect the ideals of our democracy
but it also did not steal the election
from john kerry like the democratic
party's own investigation concluded
despite the problems on election day
there is no evidence from our survey
that john kerry won the state of ohio
but of course that report was written
months later the morning after the
election john kerry still believed he
might have won and he was furious with
the partisanship he saw in the Ohio
election but nonetheless he called
george w bush and conceded this is one
of the central tenants of our country we
have fair elections where the outcomes
are trusted broadly if not universally
and when power changes hands it does so
peacefully like it's sometimes said that
the greatest moment of George
Washington's presidency was its final
moment when he handed the office over to
John Adams and created a precedent for
how American leaders would cede power to
paraphrase something george w bush said
recently in American history the office
of the presidency is always more
important than the person who holds it
now none of this is to say that our
elections are perfect like voter
suppression has been a hallmark of us
voting and suppression efforts have
disproportionately targeted systemically
disadvantaged voters the poor initially
and then when the franchise was extended
women
and people of color even today there are
many political strategies for
suppressing voters but voter suppression
which is real is not the same thing as
widespread fraud which is not in most
states observers from both major
political parties monitor poll workers
to prevent official fraud and fraud
among voters is incredibly rare in the
United States with very few exceptions
people do not vote when they are not
allowed to or impersonate voters or vote
multiple times or vote when they are
dead the voter rolls may include dead or
otherwise ineligible people because the
rolls aren't kept up to date or purged
often enough but that does not mean
fraudulent votes will be cast like you
may have heard that in-person voter
fraud is as uncommon in the United
States as dying from a lightning strike
but that's just not true in the past 14
years there have been 31 substantiated
cases of in-person voter fraud in US
elections and 36 people have been killed
by lightning this year alone now fraud
via absentee ballots is somewhat more
common because it's easier to fill out
someone's ballot if it's mailed in but
it is not widespread and it is not
systematic you might hear about a study
showing that six point four percent of
non-citizens living in the United States
voted in 2008 that study has been
thoroughly debunked you may have heard
that certain voting machines can be
easily rigged that is just not true and
you may have heard that voting machines
owned by liberal George Soros will be
used in 16 states this year in fact
George Soros has no ownership stake in
the company in question Smartmatic and
furthermore Smartmatic machines will be
used in 0 States in 2016 by the way
links to nonpartisan sources in the
doobly-doo as usual so the u.s.
presidential election will not be rigged
any more than the one in 2004 was what's
different now is that one of the major
Party presidential candidates is loudly
and consistently claiming that the
election will be rigged that there will
be widespread voter fraud that people
may vote 10 times that undocumented
immigrants will vote and on and on and
on these are all simply lies they are
not substantiated in any way and
normalizing those conspiracy theories
frankly scares the crap out of me
because it means fewer Americans will
trust our elections even when they are
free and fair I guess I understand that
fear mongering is part of US politics
but undermining the legitimacy of our
political institutions without cause
isn't hearing
unfounded rhetoric from a presidential
candidate is a new and disturbing
development in American political
discourse so I want to be very clear
your vote will capped the election will
not be rigged if you're fortunate enough
to be an eligible voter in the United
States of America please make your voice
heard Hank I'll see you on Friday